[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ازيكم عاملين ايه انا مبسوطه
جدا جدا ان انا معكم النهارده
اللطيفه جدا دي وكان نفسي جدا ابقى موجود
على ارض الواقعه وحاولت كثير ولكن الظروف
بقى انا ابقى معكم هنا اون لاين
وزي ما انتم عارفين انا اسمي بسمه ولا لا
بس انا صناعه محتوى على اليوتيوب
حياتي كلها عباره عن صناعه محتوى يا اما
باصور يا اما بمنتج يا اما بحاول ادور على
افكار جديده
بياخذ وقت طويل جدا
في حاجات كثير
على طول على برامج المونتاج فبلاقي صباعي
على طول بيدوح اللي كنترول زيت او اللي هو
الزرار بتاع الاندومي
او اللي هو الرجوع خطوه للوراء لو مثلا
بعمل كات مثلا الكليب معين ما عجبتنيش
النتيجه فبلاقي نفسي على طول كنترول زي
حطيت صوره مثلا حسيت ان هي لا الاضاءه
بتاعتها مش حلوه مثلا او اللون بتاعها مش
لائق مع الباجراون بتاعه الفيديو كنترول
دي حطيت مثلا موسيقى معينه حسيت ان صوتها
عالي مثلا او عليت الصوت شويه حسيت انه
اوفر عالي او وطيته قوي فحسس انه مش مسموع
كنترول كنترول زيت طول الوقت فالصوابعي
بقت اخذه جدا على حتى شوفوا زي ما باقول
لكم كده دلوقت عارفه فين اللوكيشن
فالموضوع ده بقيت اعمله كثير جدا بدون وعي
اصلا من غير ما اخذ بالي ان انا باعمله
كثير قوي
فقعدت افكر مع نفسي كده انه تخيلوا تخيلي
بسمه تخيلي
لو عندك الاوبشن ده في حياتك
[موسيقى]
لو عندك اوبشن او لو عندك اختيار ان انت
كل ما تاخذي قرار غلط في حياتك ترجعي فيه
وترجعي فيه من غير عواقب يعني احنا ممكن
نرجع في قناتنا على فكره يعني على ارض
الواقع او ممكن لو فتحت شركه مثلا وفشلت
ممكن ابيعها مثلا او ممكن اصفيها لو حد
اتجوز جوازه مثلا فشلت ممكن يتطلق بس ده
مش الاندو اللي احنا بنتكلم عليه انا
بتكلم على
اللي ما فيهوش عواقب كانه زي زي زي
كده او زي المونتاج يعني انا لما باعمل
بادوس على زرار في ثانيتين مش مضطر ان انا
اروح محكمه ارفع قضيه او او ادور على حد
يشتري شركتي ااا او حاجه متعبه ممكن
اعملها هي زرار في ثواني وهمم ما فيش اي
عواق قبل الموضوع يعني الفيديوهات دول زي
ما هو همم انا هافضل زي ما انا ما فيش
حاجه هتتاثر
فتخيلوا مثلا لو حد اتجوز حد ما عجبهوش
فكنترول دي ينساه اصلا كانه ما جاش كان
الماموري دي ما حصلتش هو ده الاندو اللي
انا بتكلم عليه تخيلوا لو ده اوبشن في
حياتنا متخيلوا شكل الحقيقه كانت هتبقى
عامله ازاي يعني قعدت افكر مع نفسي كده
تخيلي لو يا سلام لو الواحد يقدر يعمل كده
يعني مش هتبقى حاجه جميله مش هتبقى حاجه
حلوه مش هتبقى حاجه اصلا مريحه كده انه
يوكن نيفر جوره ما ينفعش تغلط مستحيل تغلط
لان حتى لو غلط هتعرف تمسح الغلطه
وقعدت افكر مع نفسي كده انه بشخصيتي دي
اللي عارفني على اليوتيوب بتفرج على
فيديوهاتي هيبقى عارف ان انا حياتي مليانه
رجعت مليانه ندم ف انا عندي 29 سنه دلوقتي
لو انا كل حاجه باخذها او كل قرار باخذه
غلط برجع فيه او بعمله كان زماني دلوقتي
لسه مثلا في 2007 كان زمان ايه دلوقتي لسه
19 18 سنه 16 سنه لان هبقى لسه واقفه هناك
عماله احاول اضبط المواقف القديمه اللي
انا عملتها غلط
مش كل المواقف اللي احنا بنتحط فيها
بنلاقي نفسنا غلطانين همم الاوبشن الثاني
هو اللي بيطلع صح
ممكن يبقى ممكن يبقى في اوبشن ثلاث احنا
مش عارفين اصلا وممكن يبقى الاثنين غلط
وممكن يبقى الاثنين صح وممكن نبقى اخترنا
القرار الصح بس نحس انه غلط فلما نرجع
نختار القرار الثاني نلاقي ان هو ده الغلط
فنرجع الاولاني فاهمين قصدي يعني
هنضيع كميه وقت وكميه مجهود وكميه طاقه
رهيبه فان احنا نصلح الماضي وعلى فكره
حاجه زي كده مش بس هتاثر على الماضي ان ان
كنترول زي ده هياثر بس على الماضي بس على
فكره لا هو مش بس ياثر على الماضي كمان
هياثر على الحاضر وهيؤثر على المستقبل
ازاي بقى
انا لو داخله
مشروع مثلا
عارفه انه كده كده هينجح هل هاعمل دراسه
جدوى
هل هاقعد احسبها بالورقه والقلم
وافكر وادرس ممكن مشاريع ثانيه ممكن تبقى
افضل ادور على مستثمرين
وانزل اشوف بعيني واشوف الكومنترز هل هعمل
كده ولا هاخش على طول افتح المشروع هاحط
كل فلوسي في المشروع اللي انا داخلاه هل
حصل لي استخاره هل هدعي ربنا انه يوفقني
هل هيبقى عندي اي نوع من انواع الرهبه او
الخوف او القلق
من نتيجه المشروع ده لا لانه انا عارفه
كده كده انه حتى لو قراري طلع غلط انا
هاعمل اندو من غير ما اخسر فلوسي ومن غير
ما اخسر دلوقتي من غير ما اخسر اي فلس من
فلوسي وهدخل به مشروع تاني هيتحول
فتخيلوا قد ايه حياتنا ممكن تتغير لمجرد
ان احنا زودنا الاوبشن ده في الحياه او في
الوجود
مش هيبقى في اي نوع من انواع التفكير انا
مول في اي حاجه احنا بنعملها مش هيبقى في
استمتاع بالنتائج مش هيبقى في رهبه من
المواقف مش هيبقى في ادرينالين اصلا مش
هيبقى في ريسك في الحياه مش هيبقى فيه
مخاطر مش هيبقى فيه
اي تفكير لاي قرارات مصيريه احنا بناخذها
في حياتي مش هيبقى فيه اصلا حاجه اسمها
قرار مصيري لان وانا بعمل ادى تينغ لما
باجي امسح كليب مثلا او لما باجيء احط
صوره ده مش قرار مصيري في حياتي لان انا
عارفه ان انا ممكن ارجع فيه بسهوله فكل
حاجه في حياتنا جواز خلفه شغل شركه اي
قرار في حياتنا هيتحول القرار شبه ان انا
احطه اوديو كليب مثلا او كليب على على على
اوديو على كليب مثلا في في برنامج مونتاج
يعني لان هقدر اعمل زي ما عجبنيش
هياثر جدا على الحظر بتاعنا هياثر جدا على
المستقبل بتاعنا كمان لان الوقت اللي احنا
هنضيعه واحنا قاعدين نضبط في الماضي ونظبط
في القرارات الغلط اللي احنا عملناها
ونعيد صياغه
المواقف ونعيد صياغه كلامنا واحنا بنتكلم
على الناس
ونبولش قوي في المواقف وفي نفسنا احنا
روحنا على نفسنا حاجات ثانيه احلى بكثير
كان ممكن تحصل لنا في المستقبل لو احنا
سبنا الحياه تمشي زي ما هي
الموضوع ليه ابعاد كثير جدا هيغير جذريا
شكل الحياه اللي احنا عايشينها لو احنا
قررنا ان احنا نستعمل
في اعتقادي هو طبعا لا يمكن ده يحصل ولكن
انا ليه بتكلم على الموضوع ده بالطريقه
الخياليه دي
لان اولا اللي عرفني على اليوتيوب شانيل
هيبقى عارف ان انا مريت بتجارب وحشه جدا
جدا في حياتي وانا صغيره عندي دلوقت 29
سنه اا لما كان عندي 17 18 سنه كده فديت
ان انا اشتغل بدوام جزئي في اماكن كثير
لان انا كنت عايزه اشتغل بصراحه انا يعني
كنت عايزه اعتمد على نفسي كنت عايزه احس
ان انا كبرت بقى وان انا بقى لي رايي في
البيت وانه ما حدش يقدر يقول لي بقى
اعملي دي علشان مصروفك ما يتمنعش عنك لانه
فلوسي ما حدش هيقدر يعني يخوفني بالمصروف
ههه
اشتغلت في سن بدري قوي وهمم
اللي عرفني على اليوتيوب هيعرف قد ايه انا
اتحطيت في مواقف سخيفه جدا بسبب الشغل ده
اشغال كثير يعني حاجات كثير انا عملتها
منهم مثلا ان انا اشتغلت كثير مثلا ناس
نصبت علي في فلوس وعمري ما قدرت ان انا
اخذ حقي لان انا كنت دائما خائفه جدا او
مكسوفه ان انا اتكلم في ماديات وفلوس وكده
والناس هتقول علي ايه لو رحت طلبت مرتبي
ناس بقى لها سنه ما دفعتليش انا مكسوفه ان
انا اقول لهم عايزه مرتبي
حاجات كثير قوي قوي قوي ندمت عليها وفي
حين ان انا
ندمت عليها انا برده
قدرت بعد سنين طويله اه ان انا اتخطها بس
الحمد لله اتخطتها بدليل ان انا تكلمت
عليها على اليوتيوب من اول الفيديوهات
اللي انا عملتها على اليوتيوب كان الكلام
على المشاكل او جزء من المشاكل اللي حصلت
دي لان في حاجات لسه ما قدرتش اخذتها
بصراحه احكي لكم عليها في المستقبل
بس عموما التخطي حقيقي ونقدر ان احنا اا
يعني نمر بيه ونقدر ان احنا نعلم نفسنا زي
نتخطى المواقف الصعبه والحاجات اللي احنا
بنندم عليها ولكن ده مش معناه ان احنا ما
ندمناش اصلا لا ربنا ده والموضوع بيبقى
مؤلم وبيبقى غلس وبيبقى سخيف وبنتمنى ياه
لو رجع بي الزمن ما كنتش سبت فلاني كلامي
بالطريقه دي وما كنتش سمعت الفلاني يعدي
لايف بالطريقه دي وما كنتش سمعت الفلانه
ان هي تدخل حياتي اصلا او ان هي تكون
صاحبتي ما كنت لو سمحت لنفسي ان انا مش
عارفه ايه مش عارفه ايه مش عارفه حاجات
كثير لا تعد ولا تحفه ولكن زرار الكنترول
دي مش موجود في الحقيقه ولا كنترول زي ولا
فاست فور وورك ولا اي حاجه من الحاجات دي
موجوده بس الحاجه الموجوده ودي حاجه لطيفه
قوي هي الزرار بتاع البوز يا جماعه عارفين
البوز احنا في اللاب توب بنستعمل اللي هو
المسطره الطويله دي علشان نوقف الفيديو هو
بنعمله مونتاج
فالبوز ده هو اللي هيبقى فعلا فعلا مفيد
وايجابي جدا جدا في حياتنا لو موجود لو
الزرار ده موجود يعني تخيلوا مثلا ههه في
موقف صعب مثلا احد بيسالك سؤال محرج مثلا
مش عارف ترد عليه ازاي وحاسس ان هو قليل
الذوق قوي ان هو سال السؤال ده ازاي يعني
يقول السؤال ازاي يعني يسالني مثلا مرتبك
كم ولا ازاي مثلا طنط تسالني مثلا انت لسه
ما جاوبتيش لحد دلوقت يا حبيبتي بقى عندهم
احفاد
تخيل لو انت في الوقت ده عندك زرار هوز
تخيل بدل ما يبقى عندك زرار كنترول زي
اللي يخليك ما تروحش اصلا الخروجه دي او
ماتشوفش اصلا الانسان ده او ما تتحطش اصلا
في الموقف ده لا
كنترول دي مش مهم قد البوز اللي يخليك تقف
ثانيه افكر 10 ثواني
اقول ايه كل بقى الحاجات بتاعه الكلام
اللي بتيجي لنا قبل ما ننام بالليل دي انا
ازاي ما ردتش قلت كذا انا ازاي سمحت لهم
يقولوا كذا تقدروا بقى تفتكروها في 10
ثواني بتوع الفوز دول
بيتهيا لي دي هتبقى حاجه تحفه هتغير حاجات
كثير جدا في حياتنا
بس المفاجاه ان زرار الفوز ده اكشن
الموجود
انت ممكن تعمل في اي لحظه ان انت تفصل
عود نفسك تفصل
لو انت
عايز ترد على سؤال دلوقتي اتسالته ممكن
تقف مع نفسك ثلاث ثواني عود نفسك لما تيجي
تتكلم عن حاجه او لما تيجي تتريقت على
حاجه او تتصرف في موقف معين او الدفاعك
عود نفسك تعد لحد ثلاثه واحد اثنين ثلاثه
واي اي هبت في الحياه او اي عاده انت عايز
تعود نفسك ان انت تعملها بصفه مستمره
هتاخذ منك 21 يوم عارفين التوينتي
21 يوم في ناس بتاخذ اكثر من كده بتوصل
لحد 66 يوم وفي ناس 185 يوم تقريبا او 180
يوم حاجه كده بس
تقدر على ارض الواقع لو مررت نفسك على
حاجه لمده 21 يوم ان انت تعملها بعد كده
بدون وعي تبقى جزء من شخصيتك فلو مره انت
نفسك ان انت تفوز قبل ما تتكلم او قبل ما
تتصرف في اي موقف وفي اي حاجه في الحياه
بعد 21 يوم او خلينا نقول بعد شهر هتلاقي
ان هي بقت جزء منك وهتلاقي ان هي بقت حاجه
سهله ان انت تعملها
فانت قولوا لي لو عندكم الاوبشن ده
هتستعملوه ولا لا الكنترول دي الاندو
هتستعملوه ولا لا ولا هتفضلوا ان انتم
تستعملوا الفوز شكرا
[موسيقى]